I'm RJ. I'm one half of WD Detailing,
and today we're going to
be showing you how we clean
quite possibly the
muddiest WS6 Firebird ever.
It was involved in a really
bad flood in Kentucky.
The car was absolutely covered,
basically head to toe, in caked-on mud,
to the point to where the mud had dried
and it was starting to crack,
almost like a desert floor.
Rock hard.
I can only assume that it was involved
in very fast-moving water,
it picked up sediment
from somewhere nearby,
and then it dried out.
So, the first step is removing
pretty much anything
except for the dashboard
and the steering wheel
and the steering column,
because that was a
little bit more involved
than we really had time for.
We're using the vacuum to remove
any residual water in
the back of the trunk.
Going into this detail,
I knew a lot of this vehicle
was going to be sold for parts.
Because there was only X amount made
and only a certain amount
of parts available,
it wouldn't make sense to scrap that car,
especially with so many
parts still being functional.
It changed some of the ways
that we were going to
be cleaning the vehicle
and using some methods
that we wouldn't use in a normal detail.
And we've never done this before,
but we literally took a pressure washer
and sprayed out the whole
interior of the vehicle
in order to remove all the mud.
So, the reason why we wouldn't do that
in a normal detail job is
it would definitely damage
some of the electrical
components of the vehicle
if you didn't give the
car ample time to dry.
So if this was a normal
vehicle that we did that in,
we would have to disconnect the battery
and then make sure that it dried out
for over five or six days.
With a car in this condition,
to clean the carpet was again different
than most vehicles that
we see on a daily basis.
So we probably spent about 45 minutes
just pressure washing gallons of water
into the carpet in order to try and flush
as much mud out of it as possible.
Well, not only that;
we had to flip it over
and spray out mud on the other side.
And then we actually had
to let it drain overnight
to try and dry out as much as we could
before we put it back in the next day
to then continue to
clean it inside the car.
So, once the carpet is dry,
we then place it back into the vehicle
and we use carpet soap.
You spray it onto the carpet,
and then I actually use the extractor
to add more water
in order to create a soapier solution,
and then you agitate it
using a brush that connects to a drill
to release some of the dirt
and grime or the stains
that are contained
within the carpet fibers,
bring them to the top,
so then you can suck it
away with the extractor.
In the extractor we only use water.
If you spray the soap onto the carpet
and if you only have
water in your extractor,
when you see through the
head of the extractor
that there's no more foam,
there's no more bubbles or soap
that's coming out of the carpet,
you know you've not only removed
the contaminants that were in the carpet,
but also any residue from leftover soap.
When we were cleaning the leather,
we had to pressure wash
the majority of the mud
away first in order to
even reveal the leather
to follow a normal type
of detailing method.
There was too much mud on the surface
to really remove it in any other way.
So that's not typically how
we would clean leather seats,
but drastic cases call
for drastic measures.
We then used an all-purpose
cleaner in a Tornador.
It's basically compressed air
that feeds into a reservoir
that holds an all-purpose cleaner,
and then it uses that compressed air
to pick up the solution and blast it into
the material that you're trying to clean.
We'll use it when we know that
the leather has seen a lot of age
and we don't want to
potentially damage it further.
And then I went ahead
and used a leather brush
in order to agitate that further
and to remove as much mud
and sediment as possible.
These would have to dry
for another couple days
in a heated storage facility.
With the exterior, we went ahead
and just did a pretty basic wash.
So we had to make sure that
we just blew out all the mud
from all the cracks and crevices there.
The foam cannon is my
personal favorite part
when it comes to washing
the exterior of a vehicle.
Foam and soap is the same thing.
It's actually like shaving cream.
You spray it onto your hand,
and as you lather it up,
it becomes more foamy.
It helps break down some of the grime,
the grease, the sediment on the vehicle
and then lifts it to the top,
and that way as you're washing,
there's both lubrication as
well as cleaning properties
that help you remove the dirt and grime
as efficiently and safely as possible.
Cleaning the windows,
most people ask what
solution you're using,
what window cleaner are you using,
but in reality,
it's the type of towel that you use
and how many towels you use
and how clean they are.
So, windows are very prone to streaking,
especially when they've
been splattered with mud,
like they were in this vehicle.
So to start out, we just use
your standard shop towels
in order to remove the bulk of the grime,
and then we use another type of towel
that's called GSM.
So it has a higher grams per square meter
of microfiber, and all that means is that
there's more fibers on the towel,
and the more grams per square meter,
the fluffier the towel
and the more microfiber strands there are
to wipe away any of the streaks.
They actually were able to get that car
running again, though.
It still functions, but
with a good conscious,
they can't sell that car to another owner.
When you finish it and you
look back at the result,
we laugh because it's almost like,
I don't know how it came out so well,
but somehow it does.